right well mathematicians always talk  about a beauty mathematics but has never  been quite clear whether the same kind  of beauty same appreciation of beauty as  people have in the arts and humanities  so together with my colleagues at  University College London working  neuroscience we devised an experiment  and this experiment which is nowadays  you can conduct without cutting people  open up about marvellous technology well  long story short this experiment showed  conclusively that the part of the brain  that's appreciates mathematical beauty  is the same part of the brain that  appreciates beauty in other fields so  scientifically it's been and that  suddenly - also scientific tests done  with right technology is sistex and  published by journals let's should  convincingly that in fact what we met  this is described as beauty or  appreciation of beauty he's  fundamentally the same as the notion of  beauty shared by our colleagues in the  arts and humanities